hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to the another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to talk about in this
video is how to write summations in
Sigma notation so a lot of times
students have questions about this like
how do you write a sum okay okay like a
series a sequence by the way is just a
list of numbers a series is a sum and
what we want to do is we want to write
this summation okay this is the sum of
all these numbers in a more compact form
and that's what we call the Sigma
notation this Greek letter here is Sigma
okay and what you do is you you want to
pick a variable okay this is your index
here I've said I equals 1 meaning I'm
starting at the first term is going to
be I equals 1 and I'm gonna work my way
up sequentially okay in order until I
get to the nth term that's the last term
so I'll show you what I mean let's take
a look at some examples so in this first
example notice what's happening here
we're adding two each time to get to the
next term so we need a formula for any
term in this sequence so what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to use the
arithmetic ok sequence formula and
basically what this is is the first term
plus the common difference times n minus
1 okay so the first term is 3 but we
keep adding 2 n minus 1 times so this is
going to be 2 n minus 2 plus 3 which is
2 n plus 1 and you can test that out you
can see when that is 1 you're getting 3
if n is you know 4 you're getting 9 and
so on okay so this is working with
sequences in series I have some other
videos I'll have some links for that for
you to check out but the main thing here
is how do we write this in this compact
Sigma notation well we have a formula to
find any term that's 2n plus 1 okay and
we're going to say that N equals 1 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 terms 2 8 okay now you're
probably saying well why are using
letter n well you can use any letter you
want you could rewrite this as
I equals 1 to 8 of 2 I plus 1 you could
say K equals 1 to 8 of 2 k plus 1 but
notice that whatever variable I'm using
here I'm using here ok so I I and and
and so on so that I I know and when
somebody looks at this they know that
okay I start with 1 I put 1 in 2 times 1
is 2 plus 1 is 3 plus the cave the Greek
letter e Sigma this means summation when
we use we're adding these up now I put 2
in for K that's 2 times 2 is 4 plus 1 is
5 and I keep working my way until I get
to this top number 8 I put 8 and I get
16 plus 1 is 17 and then I add all those
together ok so right now we're just
practicing running it as a summation
okay so the next one what's the pattern
here like how am I getting from this
term to this term for this term and so
on
okay so we're multiplying by 1/2 right
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start off we're going to say our formula
is 100 okay times 1/2 we'll say I minus
1 times so you start off with a hundred
you multiply a by 1/2 by half by half so
if I wanted to get to the one two three
fourth term I actually have to multiply
by 1/2 once twice three times which is
one less than the actual term that I'm
on turn number four so I equals 1 and
what's the top number here well if you
said infinity you're right because this
keeps going see the ellipsis the three
dots that just means it keeps going okay
so this is just gonna be an infinite
series okay it just goes on and on and
on alright last example this one here it
actually doesn't fit the arithmetic
pattern where you're adding or
subtracting the same thing each time
doesn't fit the geometric pattern where
you're multiplying or dividing by the
same thing each time this one is just
its own unique pattern and you can see
it's one half plus two-thirds plus
three-fourths so on and so forth but
notice how the numerator keeps going up
by 1 and the denominator keeps going up
by one so what we're going to do is
we're going to write this like so we're
going to say that the n over n plus 1
that's our formula for any term
and N equals 1 to 99 because you can see
the first term N equals 1 second term n
equals 2 all the way to the 99th turn
any N equals 99 and then the denominator
is always one more than the numerator so
that's why we have n plus 1 and so this
is just a compact representation of how
to write this summation ok this series
which is the sum of terms and a nice
compact form so I hope you enjoyed this
video I hope you learned something
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I'll see you in
the next video